Transcription: Emmanuelle hardan
Relecteur: Anne-Sophie Matichard
Bonjour à toutes et à tous,
Je m’appelle Marion Gyral et j’ai 40 ans.
Et nous allons passer
une quinzaine de minutes ensemble
pour parler de la confiance en l’avenir.
La raison pour laquelle
on va et on doit parler
de la confiance en l’avenir,
c’est que lorsque j’ai prononcé ce mot,
« avenir »,
pour certains, c’est un champ
des possibles qui s’est ouvert,
et pour d’autres,
c’est la boule au ventre,
un gouffre d’incertitude
qui s’est réveillé.
Certains d’entre vous auront peut-être
prévu où ils allaient manger ce soir,
planifié leurs prochaines vacances,
comment ils vont s’habiller demain,
ce qu’ils vont faire à la rentrée.
D’autres encore vont peut-être passer par
la crainte de manquer d’argent,
de tomber malade,
d’oser aborder un homme, une femme.
Et d’autres encore ont peut être
l’envie profonde
de changer quelque chose
dans leur vie, là, maintenant,
mais sans trop savoir comment se projeter.
Je suis thérapeute psycho-corporel.
J’ai pu observer au cours
de ces seize ans
que le monde se divise plutôt
en deux catégories :
ceux qui ont peur de l’avenir
et ceux qui s'y projettent avec confiance.
Et que pour passer
d’une catégorie à l’autre,
il y a trois clés qui sont essentielles.
La première, c'est revenir
à l'instant présent.
La deuxième, c’est comprendre
son histoire.
Et la troisième, c'est poser de l'amour
sur ce qui nous fait mal.
Mais avant tout, il y a
deux mécanismes fondamentaux
qui sont essentiels à comprendre.
On est tous uniques.
Vous êtes tous uniques.
Chaque enfant grandit dans un
environnement familial, culturel,
et éducatif différent.
On n'a pas la même histoire.
On n’est pas né au même moment,
au même endroit, de la même façon.
Et le cerveau de l’enfant
se sculpte différemment
en fonction des expériences qu’il intègre.
Même au sein d’une même fratrie,
quelquefois, on n’a pas le même vécu
des événements.
Souvent, j’entends :
« Alors lui, il n’a pas le même père
ou la même mère que moi ! »
Ben non, on n’est pas né au même moment,
on n’est pas à la même place.
Même nos parents, ils ont pas
la même histoire,
ils ont leur moule à eux, leurs blessures,
et ils en font ce qu’ils peuvent.
Au fur et à mesure, le cerveau de l’enfant
se développe de plus en plus.
Le système de pensée se structure de plus
en plus avec les croyances et les valeurs.
Et à partir de trois ans, l’enfant est
en capacité de se rappeler
de plus en plus longtemps des souvenirs
grâce à la myéline dans le cerveau.
Et à l’âge adulte, grâce au néocortex,
on est capable de faire
quelque chose d’incroyable.
C'est de voyager dans le temps.
Et notre conception du futur se sculpte
en fonction de ce qu’on croit,
de ce qu’on a vécu dans notre passé,
pas forcément de la réalité,
mais de ce qu’on croit avoir vécu.
On est très fort pour se faire des films,
on n’arrête pas.
On va prendre l’exemple
d’une illustre inconnue
qui est là, tranquille, sur son canapé .
Et puis c'est parti.
Elle se projette.
C’est le cinéma à la maison,
et en plus, c’est gratuit.
Elle est là, elle s’imagine avec un homme,
elle vit une idylle,
elle est bien, elle sent que
les émotions sont là,
elle vit son truc quoi.
Et puis les années passent
et ça se dégrade :
« De toute façon c’est toujours comme ça !
Fallait que ça arrive comme ça,
les mecs, c’est tous des connards.
Y’en a marre,
ça finit toujours comme ça ! »
Et elle est là, elle s’emporte,
elle n’en peut plus.
Bon.
Elle est dans tous ses états,
mais on n’a pas oublié que, elle,
elle est chez elle,
sans rendez-vous et célibataire.
Qu’est-ce qui s’est passé là ?
C’est que tout simplement
son cerveau,
il se projette en fonction
de ce qu’elle a vécu.
Elle aura sûrement vécu une histoire
compliquée au niveau affectif
ou assisté à des histoires compliquées.
Autrement dit, si toute votre enfance
vous avez pioché des « w »,
il y a fort à parier qu’adulte,
vous aurez du mal à jouer au Scrabble.
En plus, 95% des pensées que va produire
votre cerveau aujourd’hui
sont les mêmes qu’hier
et que demain.
(Rires)
Le cerveau, lui, prend toute la place.
Même si c’est stressant, il gère,
il contrôle, il occupe toute la place.
Alors, c’est quoi l’inconvénient
de tout ça ?
Mais c’est qu’à force,
notre système mental nous coupe.
Il nous coupe du corps,
de nos émotions,
de notre état intuitif,
de nos perceptions,
de ce qui raisonne là, à l’intérieur.
Il nous coupe de notre état naturel
de confiance.
Et tout l’enjeu, c’est de refaire
de la place à cet espace là .
Alors comme je le disais au début,
pour ça, il y a trois clés.
La première, c’est revenir
à l’instant présent,
parce que notre cerveau
est hyper perfectionné,
mais il nous sort en permanence
de l’instant présent.
Il se projette constamment dans le temps.
Alors l'instant présent,
c'est pas une théorie.
C’est un état naturel de confiance,
inscrit dans le corps
depuis le stade embryonnaire.
C'est l'intelligence mentale au service
du corps, tout simplement.
Lorsque l’enfant apprend à marcher,
il apprend, c’est tout.
C’est naturel.
À chaque pas, la confiance s’inscrit
naturellement dans le corps.
Il fonctionne à l’intuition,
il gère pas et ça marche.
Il y a un truc que vous avez fait 127 fois
depuis que j’ai commencé à parler.
À votre avis, c’est quoi ?
(Public) « Respirer. »
MG : Oui !
(Rires)
127 fois, vous avez respiré.
127 fois, vos poumons se sont remplis.
127 fois, ils se sont vidés, lentement.
127 fois, votre diaphragme
s’est contracté.
Et la vie est là, dans l’instant présent.
L’adulte est absorbé par tout,
son portable, son compte en banque,
ses enfants, son couple, son job.
Sauf par son espace intérieur.
Et le corps est le meilleur indicateur
qu’il soit, dans l’instant présent.
Si je prends l’exemple d’un grand océan,
où les vagues sont l’avenir
et où je suis avec ma planche de surf.
Je suis pas en capacité de décider
combien de temps vont durer ces vagues,
jusqu’où elles vont et leur intensité.
Deux solutions s'offrent à moi.
La première, soit mon cerveau projette
du stress sur la vague à venir,
il va essayer de gérer, mais j’aurais déjà
pris les vagues dans la tête,
j’essaierai peut-être de remonter,
mais je serais très fatiguée.
Soit j’accueille dans l’instant présent
et je prends cette vague
et ça me remplit d’énergie, de confiance,
parce que simplement,
je fais confiance à mon corps.
La confiance est là,
à l’intérieur du corps, tout simplement.
Alors pour retrouver encore
cette confiance dans l’avenir,
la deuxième clé,
c’est de comprendre notre histoire,
questionner nos croyances,
sortir de l’état de victime.
Un célèbre biologiste, Bruce Lipton,
a fait des études sur les croyances
et a démontré que nos croyances influent
directement sur notre biologie interne.
Certaines croyances vont parasiter
le bon fonctionnement de notre cerveau
et du corps,
et d’autres, au contraire,
vont faciliter la résilience.
On peut questionner notre histoire :
« Ok, j’ai vécu ça, mais qu’est-ce
que je fais de mes croyances ? »
On peut décider ce qu’on a envie de garder
pour la vie qu’on a envie
de vivre maintenant.
Si à cinq ans, j’ai la croyance
de pas parler aux inconnus,
elle est nécessaire pour me protéger
d’un danger éventuel.
Si à 40 ans, je garde cette même croyance,
je vais être mal barrée pour parler
devant vous aujourd’hui !
Je vais plutôt partir en courant.
On peut agir sur le milieu
qui agit sur nous.
Alors je vais vous raconter
une petite histoire.
C’est l’histoire d’une petite fille
qui a grandi dans
un environnement bienveillant,
avec quatre enfants.
Et elle, c’est la dernière de la fratrie.
À ses dix ans, son père a développé
une dépression nerveuse.
À ses treize ans,
il s’est donné la mort.
Cette petite fille, c'est moi.
Comme vous pouvez l’imaginer,
à ce moment-là, en tant qu’enfant,
j’ai dû passer par les étapes de deuil,
apprendre à vivre avec la mort
et par la peur aussi que l’autre parent
disparaisse également.
Mais ce qui est important,
c’est que sans cette histoire,
je ne serais pas là,
à vous parler aujourd’hui.
J'ai vécu dans un environnement
émotionnel très dense.
On ne m’a pas tout expliqué,
tout le monde était sous le choc.
Rien n'était clair.
Et en tant qu’enfant,
mon cerveau s’est adapté
à l’environnement que
j’étais en train de vivre,
aux événements auxquels
je devais faire face.
J’ai développé des perceptions intuitives
très fortes.
J’ai écouté les corps.
Observé les silences.
Ressenti les vibrations.
Le non perceptible est devenu ma lecture.
Par la suite, j’ai pu questionner,
poser des questions, avoir des réponses,
et j’ai compris mon histoire.
J’ai développé de plus en plus
ces perceptions intuitives,
jusqu’à ce qu’elles deviennent ma force
et que je les utilise
pour mon accompagnement thérapeutique,
dans ma vie de tous les jours.
On peut agir sur le milieu
qui agit sur nous.
Et c’est ce qui nous amène aussi
à la troisième clé,
après être revenu dans l’instant présent,
après avoir compris l’histoire,
et c’est sûrement l’ingrédient magique
des deux autres clés,
c’est de poser de l’amour
sur ce qui nous fait mal.
Parce que notre douleur sculpte
notre cerveau,
mais aussi elle sculpte notre corps.
Si je prends le temps d’accueillir
pleinement la blessure dans mon corps,
de la ressentir, ne pas être en lutte avec
ce que je traverse
et d’apporter tout l’amour nécessaire
à ces parties de moi,
derrière, la joie est là.
On est tous contraints par un
environnement familial
qui va mettre en lumière ou éteindre
nos différences, ce qui nous rend uniques.
C’est dans l’acceptation
de nos différences qu’est notre confiance.
Notre pouvoir d’action il est là,
à l’intérieur du corps, à travers l’amour.
On a tous quelque chose à offrir au monde.
Capter ce qui nous donne de l’énergie,
ce dont on pourrait parler pendant
deux, trois heures.
Donner ce qu’on aime offrir au monde,
ce qui fait qu’on se sent rempli, plein.
On nous relance sur le sujet,
on est fatigué, on nous relance
et wow c’est parti !
Plus je vais être dans l’acceptation
de ces différences,
plus je vais rencontrer des personnes,
créer des opportunités
qui vont nourrir mes valeurs profondes,
mes valeurs essentielles.
Si notre illustre inconnue est là
et qu’elle prend le temps
d’accueillir ses blessures
à l’intérieur du corps,
de comprendre son histoire,
elle trouvera quelqu’un ou pas,
c’est pas grave.
Ce qui est important, c’est qu’elle
ne sera plus en lutte avec elle-même.
Alors pour terminer, deux choses :
je vous invite tous
à poser votre cerveau en mode avion.
À mettre l’intelligence mentale
au service du cœur,
de ce qui résonne là, à l’intérieur.
De ressentir pleinement cette confiance.
Et d'offrir au monde ce que
vous avez de plus beau.
Et je vous invite demain matin,
c’est un petit exercice,
lorsque vous vous réveillerez, à ne pas
allumer le portable tout de suite ;
posez les pieds au sol
et inspirez profondément
et expirez profondément.
Et je vous invite à remercier votre
corps pour son bon fonctionnement,
parce que lui, il bosse le jour et
la nuit pendant que nous, on pense.
Le remercier pour toute l’énergie
qu’il développe, tout le temps.
Parce que lorsque la gratitude est là,
la confiance est là, naturellement.
Merci à tous, et à toutes.
(Applaudissements)